[Music]  it is finally fall which means it is  finally time to change up our wardrobes  so we teamed up with Stitch fix to get  me ready for my many upcoming red  carpets with some personalized looks  we're having a shoulder moment here's  how easy all of this was all I did was  take a quick style quiz and then a  selection of items matching my personal  style were literally delivered to my  office and get this delivery spree you  all know I love a country denim moment  but here's the thing I already own a  similar pair of heels so I might need to  send these ones back but no worries  because there's free returns  how fun is this Stitch fix is such a  great shopping solution for my nights  out or even big celebrations and work  events  [Music]